- Hi, good evening.
My name is Alan Gerber.
I'm the director of the
Institution for Social
and Policy Studies at Yale.
ISPS is holding a series
of events this year,
bringing together experts
from Yale and beyond,
to shed light on key questions
concerning American politics,
governance and democracy.
Tonight's event is
sponsored by ISPS Democracy,
which is an ISP program that
aims to further research,
and public discussion,
of representation and
democratic policy making.
We have a number of events
planned for this spring.
Please be on the lookout for them.
If you would like to learn
more about these ISPS events,
through ISPS Democracy
and also ISPS Research,
please visit the ISPS
website, isps.yale.edu.
And I would like to just begin
by not only thanking the panelists,
but also thanking the
organizers of the panel,
Pam Greene, Pam Lamonaca,
Tory Bilski and Limor Peer.
So, here's the logistics
for tonight's event.
After I introduce the panelists,
and we have a panel presentation
and a panel discussion,
there will be a question
and answer period.
Please send questions
throughout the session,
using the Q and A button at
the bottom of the Zoom screen.
It's very useful, if you
can keep your questions
to a relatively compact
short sentence or two,
that facilitates both our
ability to process the question,
and also to field it to the panelists.
I also wanna note that tonight's
event is being recorded,
and also that if you need
technical assistance,
just email isps@yale.edu.
So, let me now welcome
tonight's panelists.
I'm gonna introduce all three
of the panelists at once,
and then they're gonna
speak in alphabetical order,
once the introduction is concluded.
First, Phil Goff is the
Carl Hovland Professor,
of African American Studies in Psychology.
Phil joined the faculty in 2020.
He is the co-founder and CEO
of the Center for Policing Equity,
which is the world's largest
research and action think tank,
on race and policing.
And it hosts an unparalleled collection,
of police behavioral data,
in the National Science Foundation funded,
National Justice Database.
Professor Goff is a
recognized national leader,
in the science of
policing and racial bias.
Dr. Goff has won two American
Psychological Association
Early Career Awards,
the Association for Psychological
Science Rising Star Award,
and the National Organization
of Black Law Enforcement
Executives Lloyd Sealy Award,
among many others.
He was also a panelist on
President Obama's Task Force,
on 21st century policing has provided,
congressional testimony on many occasions
and regularly appears on cable
news and other media outlets.
We're delighted to have
Phil Goff here this evening.
Our second speaker will be Jacob Hacker.
Jacob is the Stanley B Resor
Professor of Political Science,
and he served as ISPS
director from 2011 to 2020.
He's a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences,
the National Academy of Social Insurance,
and also was the 2020
Robert Ball Award winner,
for the National Academy
of Social Insurance.
He's known for his writings and research,
on American politics and public policy,
and as a pioneer in the
development of healthcare policy
especially the public option.
Look forward to your remarks, Jacob.
And then we have Fiona Scott Morton.
Scott Morton is the Theodore
Nierenberg Professor
of Economics at the School of Management,
has been on the faculty since 1999,
served as SOM Associate
Dean from 2007 to 2010.
And from 2011 to 2012,
Professor Scott Morton,
served as the Deputy
Assistant Attorney General
for Economics at the Antitrust Division
of the US Department of Justice,
where she helped formulate and enforce,
the nation's antitrust laws and policies.
In 2019, Scott Morton founded
the Thurmond Arnold Project
at Yale named in honor of Thurmond Arnold,
Yale law professor and head
of the Antitrust Division,
from 1938 to 1943.
And this is a program that brings together
Yale faculty and students,
from across the
university, the law school,
the school of management,
as well as scholars from other
institutions to collaborate
on research related to
competition, competition policy,
and antitrust enforcement.
Welcome Fiona, I look forward
to your remarks as well.
So, with that, we can get started.
Phil, we'll start off
then Jacob then Fiona
- Thanks very much, Alan.
And thank you everybody
for spending part of this,
at least in the Northeast,
very snowy Tuesday in February.
My understanding is that
according to my students,
every time I lecture it snows.
So, I was not aware that coming
to Yale gave me these swarms
of superpowers over nature,
but thank you also for that.
We were asked to talk about two things,
in a sort of brief set
of introductory remarks.
One is something that we
think is going to happen,
in our issue area.
And one is something that
we think should happen,
and I assume it was implied,
but we're not as confident is going to.
So, to give you a context
of sort of what I
imagine my issue area is,
it's the body politic of
race in the United States,
but particularly within public safety.
I don't know if any of you
guys noticed over the summer,
but that was in the news a lot.
Part of the reason was
obviously the conflagration
that started in Minneapolis,
swept across the entire country,
and then became a global enterprise.
Really a global reckoning
with issues of state violence,
race, and social hierarchy.
But part of it is part of the cycle,
that we go through in this country,
where we look at,
I won't say we reckon
with 'cause we don't,
but we look at the
massive past due notice,
of the unpaid debt owed to
black folks in this country.
I'm not necessarily only talking
about reparations for slavery,
but I am also talking about
slavery and its consequences.
And in the wake of the summer,
part of what we saw was
an awakening to literally,
they're calling it
re-imagining public safety.
But it's an awakening of
the public imagination,
for what's possible in
response to violations
of the social contract,
amongst the most vulnerable.
Think about it like this.
If I choose to take Alan's wallet, right,
then we can understand that,
as me choosing to
violate the sacred trust,
that allows us to live
together, that social contract,
and I should have some consequences.
But if part of the calculus
for me taking Alan's wallet,
is Alan or other deans
having taken so much from me,
that there aren't really
other good options, right?
I understand that this
metaphor gets fantastical,
when we're talking about
senior faculty at Yale,
but run with me for a little bit here.
If the deal is that I have been placed,
with a band set of
options and I choose one,
that violates the social contract,
when in reality, the
social contract really just
never included me in the first place.
Why is punishment our
only response to that?
Why is it that when someone
chooses a bad option,
with a set of bad
choices in front of them,
that they have that punishment
funded by the State,
in communities that are
disproportionately inhabited
by the descendants of
formerly enslaved people
in this country, why is
that our policy solution?
So, that's a big part of
what this new administration
is having to wrestle with.
And in that moment, the
defund and the re-imagining,
another word has more recently appeared,
and that word is abolition.
And I wanna to couch
both of my answers about,
what I think will happen,
what I think should happen
in the context of abolition.
The way we talk about abolition
of the prison industrial complex,
which is historically has
been mostly prisons and jails,
and now increasingly
includes sheriffs and police.
We think about that as simply
the removal of the bad thing,
the cancer that is that is
poisoning the body politic.
But one of the greatest sort
of champions of the idea
of particularly prison
abolition, Angela Davis,
when she writes in 2005,
essentially a retrospective
of her life's work to that point,
she calls the book, "Abolition Democracy,"
which is a hearkening back
to the language of Du Bois
in 1935, when he's talking
about black reconstruction.
And her first book in 1971,
while incarcerated, right,
called, "When They Come in the Morning,"
it's a collection of essays from people
who have been involved in
the criminal legal system,
and she chooses Julian Bond
to write the forward to that.
And what does Julian Bond write about,
Du Bois in 1935 saying, no
one has done anything since.
So, when Du Bois talks
about abolition democracy,
he's not talking about the
US system post emancipation,
post-slavery.
He's talking about an
affirmative construction,
of political and systemic structures,
that rent the body politic
of the toxins of slavery.
It's not just the removal of the injury,
it's the healing from it,
that needs to take
generations afterwards, right?
Now, that word abolition is straining,
what's been possible on the political left
and activist basis.
'Cause it's set up as counter two reform.
The idea that you could
fix the thing that is,
no, sometimes you've got to
burn it down and start a new.
That's the conversation happening
outside of Washington, DC,
in terms of how we manage things
that will gotta call crime
but really it's violations
of the social contract,
among the most vulnerable.
So, as my time starts to
begin to come to an end,
what do I think is going to happen?
And what do I think should happen?
What's going to happen is that,
this administration which
is made up of a mix,
of folks who are old
guard, people doing reform,
trying to fix the things that we've got,
I have a mix of folks
who are really excited
for something new,
there is going to be
stuff put on the table,
that looks exactly like what it did,
at the end of the previous administration.
That makes specifically the
Justice and Policing Act, right?
This is a bill that
passed out of the house,
didn't get a vote on
the floor of the Senate,
in part because there were
competing ideas about it.
But in part because, frankly
there was no incentive,
for anybody to introduce it.
What it will do is set
for the bunch of things,
that will make policing better.
Reduce qualified immunity,
which means that if a
police officer did something
that was unreasonable, they
could be held accountable to it.
It'll lower the 242 standard,
which means that instead of
a willful discrimination,
you can get reckless.
It will allow the federal
government to engage in things
around accountability and public safety,
they haven't done before.
But what it won't do,
is set up the structures
that prevent someone
from having to call
911 in the first place.
And it also won't allow for the resources,
that are the appropriate response,
for instance, with mental health crisis
or substance abuse crisis
or crisis of suicide.
It won't send those resources,
in response and it won't
send them affirmatively.
So, the kind of legislation
that can get through Congress
and the kind of executive orders
that will come out of
the president's desk,
the first time through,
that's gonna be the reform.
The things that are bold action,
in the context of what
happened before this summer.
But what should happen, and
I'm less sanguine about,
is a fool reckoning of
what our systems of justice
at the federal level
have failed to render,
particularly to black,
brown and native folks,
in this country.
And I mean, quite literally,
a reckoning and accounting,
what has DOJ done that
has harmed native folks,
Chicano folks, black folks?
Where can we get that codified?
'Cause that reckoning is the first step,
towards actually fixing.
I'm not calling for
massive amounts of funding
for all of that yet.
I'm calling for the infrastructure,
that makes it morally irresistible,
to take that next step.
Because as we're moving towards
progress along public safety
where I'm very concerned,
there will be a critical incident.
There will be a murder,
there'll be an assault,
there'll be something ghastly.
There'll be those who seek
to weaponize that incident,
as a cause to reinvest in the
kind of policing we've had,
up until now.
To humiliate or to embarrass
or to shame the folks,
who've been calling for
more radical change.
And if the infrastructure isn't set up,
so that we can continue to move forward,
when it's some of these
experiments that we're trying out
in many of the cities
across the country fail,
then we're gonna do the
exact same thing we've done,
every other time that we've tried
to reimagine public safety,
which is forget about the
people who most need that safety
and retrench ourselves in old orthodoxies.
So, my hope for this administration,
is that there's enough new
energy, both inside and outside,
that the pressure stays on,
that we build for the long-term
and not just in reaction
to the passions of this summer.
But what I know is going to happen,
is that incremental change
is going to move forward.
And it's going to be up to us,
to decide whether or not that's enough.
- Well, first of all,
thank you so much everyone for being here.
Thank you, Alan, Lamar, Pam,
for putting this together.
Thanks Fiona and Phil for
being part of this panel,
and thank Phil in particular
for those really stirring remarks.
My conclusions, my issue
area is completely different,
but my conclusions are somewhat similar,
and maybe this is going to
be a theme for the evening,
because the gap between
what should be done,
and what will be possible
in the immediate term,
is pretty great.
Not withstanding the
fact that those who want
to act boldly in these areas,
are in a stronger position
than we would have expected
a year or two ago.
So, let me say a bit about the issue area,
it's not gonna be a surprise to you,
that I'm gonna talk a
bit about healthcare.
Alan already said that, but I wanna,
that's a huge area and I'm not
an expert on public health.
So, I'm not going to say a huge amount
or very much at all about
the response to COVID 19.
I'm gonna focus mostly on
the unfinished business
of American Healthcare Reform.
Namely the fact that the
United States is the only,
rich democracy that lacks the
kind of two part solution,
that every other country in
that set has come up with,
a system that covers everyone,
and has some mechanism for
controlling costs system-wide.
And in particular, for
restraining healthcare prices,
which in the absence of such systems,
tend to grow much more quickly
than the cost of living,
than people's standard,
than people's incomes,
and than what governments can afford.
Fiona knows a lot about
that side of the story,
and I'll be interested
to see if her thoughts
on anti-trust extended at all
into the healthcare realm,
but the areas I'm gonna focus on really,
are around the broadening
of health insurance,
and whether or not that
broadening can go hand in hand,
with serious efforts to reign
in America's exorbitant healthcare costs.
Now, as I said, my conclusions
are somewhat similar
to Phil's, right?
We need to build for the long-term,
because we're not gonna see the kind of,
transformative change we
need in the near term.
But that's not to say,
that the changes in the
near term could not,
both make an enormous difference,
and contribute to that
longterm transformation.
Now, what is the should,
what are the transformative
changes we need?
Now, I mean, I think not
withstanding the fact
that we have, we're very far away,
from having universal insurance
and effective cost control today.
I actually think a lot
of the core elements
of what needs to be done, have
actually been articulated,
and not just by movement leaders
but by people in public office.
And I won't try to make
the argument for why,
Medicare for all may be a bridge
too far in the medium term,
but instead just say that,
whatever your views on
whether we can move,
to a universal public insurance system,
there is broad agreement
that we need to massively
expand public coverage,
and the cost controls and
rationalization that goes with it,
that we need to make sure that,
every citizen and
eventually every resident
in the United States,
has protection against
ruinous healthcare costs,
and access to medical care.
And notably, that we need to do this,
with an understanding
of what we've learned
over the last generation,
namely that the cost of
healthcare is growing so quickly,
and the private insurance models,
are shifting so much
more costs onto patients,
and restricting networks such that,
unless we put in place a system
that allows people to have
broad access to providers,
relatively affordable out
of pocket costs for care,
and coverage that's
there when they need it,
we're not gonna achieve that.
So, it's gonna require public actions.
Before the election, the
Biden campaign actually,
articulated in concert
with the Sanders Camp,
a set of principles that are now known
as the unity task force document.
And the important aspect of that was that,
a core thing that they said
was that they wanted to have
a public insurance option,
such as the one that I've
advocated for many years.
And that would be built on
the Medicare infrastructure,
and would use Medicare providers
and Medicare payment rates,
but improve those over time.
And that it would be
used to expand coverage
for people who live in States,
that where Medicaid was not expanded
in response to Affordable Care Act.
And I think if it were possible,
that would be the right
template to pursue.
The challenge of course, is that,
we are despite the fact that
those who are advocating
these reforms are in a majority position,
in the sense that the Senate,
the House and the White House,
are in the hands of the party
that would like to do these things,
that party has a very narrow majority.
And so, we've all been
debating and discussing,
the filibuster and its future,
and to a very great extent,
the extent of changes
that are possible are gonna depend,
on whether or not the filibuster
is retained in the Senate.
That debate will not play out
in the context of healthcare,
it will likely play out in
the context of voting reform.
And I don't know how it
will be resolved though.
I must say that there is more
prospect for the elimination,
of the filibuster for
ordinary legislation,
and there has been at any
point in the last 25 years,
but that that prospect
still seems fairly elusive,
given the current configuration of power.
So, given that I've written recently
that I think it's very important that,
those who are in support of
the more ambitious reforms
I've articulated,
or even more ambitious reforms,
like moving to a
universal Medicare system,
really need to think about how to use,
the opportunities that we
have in the medium term,
to lay the groundwork
for longer-term change.
So, this is really
similar to the challenge,
that Phil was talking about.
I do think it's about movement building,
but it's also about
doing what I've called,
using power to build, using
policy to build power.
So, how do you put in place policies,
that will build constituencies and trust
and positive results that
will make it more likely
that you can move towards
more ambitious reforms
in the future?
I've wrote a whole article on this,
in the journal of health,
politics, policy and law,
that just came out.
But the three elements
that I've emphasized are,
those who are seeking these
more ambitious reforms,
need to upgrade the Affordable Care Act
and in particular, to make it more,
it's subsidies more generous for coverage,
and to fix a lot of the defects in the law
that had been introduced
or were not fixed,
in the last administration.
And there's already a
lot of executive action,
that's moved in that direction,
but it's gonna take a legislation.
The second thing that I've argued is that,
you need to build the
infrastructure for bigger reforms,
and that would mean improving
and expanding key aspects,
of Medicare in particular,
making Medicare a better
program for older Americans
and a more efficient program.
And then finally,
I think it's extremely important
to try to build movements
and that's been involved policy.
So, if you think about the COVID response,
the idea of building a
public health jobs core
that could help enroll
people and coverage,
could be a really important part of also,
building political power
and grassroots enthusiasm,
for broader reforms in the future.
The last thing I'll say is that,
there really is in the
absence of the filibuster
only one fast track in
American politics today,
it's called the budget
reconciliation process.
And the budget reconciliation
process will be the vehicle
for the current legislation,
the pandemic relief
legislation before Congress.
You only get one and at most in this year,
two bites of the reconciliation apple.
And that means that the
challenge is gonna be,
whether the next big
reconciliation bill will,
include core healthcare provisions.
Remember there's also a huge
push for infrastructure,
and a abroad response to climate change.
And I think that there's a real question,
of whether or not you can do these kinds
of reforms simultaneously.
And next year, we're already going to be
into an election year that's gonna be,
deeply freighted in 2022.
And so, to me in the absence
of filibuster reform,
the agenda for healthcare reform,
is likely gonna be more limited
than many advocates would want,
simply because of the
crowded reform agenda,
that's gonna occur with
only one big fast train,
leaving the station.
But with that, I'm gonna
return to my earlier remarks
and say, that one should not despair,
but think about the ways in
which these opportunities
in the near term could be used to build,
power and better policy for the longterm.
- Great, I guess I'm up next.
It was wonderful to listen to both of you.
I will actually echo Jacob and say,
that I have that same theme
in the following sense.
My area of expertise is, as Alan said,
competition policy in antitrust.
And people don't usually
think of antitrust
as social justice.
But it is for the following reason.
Most shareholders,
most people entitled to corporate
profits, monopoly profit,
are the top 1%, and the
top 1% are mostly white.
And when you take a dollar
of corporate profit,
and you turn it into competition instead,
those monopoly profits don't get earned,
and they get turned into low
prices or better quality.
And those benefit all consumers.
And all consumers are
obviously much more diverse
than the top one or 5%.
So, when we enforce the competition,
then when we make our
markets more competitive,
we are in fact redistributing income,
reducing income inequality,
and helping the more
vulnerable disproportionately.
So, the last 40 years of evidence,
has now been made much more clear,
I would say over the
last five or 10 years,
to tell us that we have
competition problem
in the United States,
we do not have enough competitive markets,
we have too many monopolies
and settings with market power.
What should we do about that?
One thing we could do is to
strengthen the antitrust laws.
This is already happening.
Senator Amy Klobuchar has
already introduced a bill,
to strengthen the antitrust laws.
This is excellent, there'll be more ideas,
I think in this area, maybe
more bills that would be great.
There's bipartisan support
for reforming the antitrust
laws in the house.
I expect that we will get a movement here,
and the reason is because,
additional antitrust enforcement
and strong grantee trust laws,
would generate more competition
which as I said is good for consumers
especially the bottom end,
that appeals to Democrats.
Republicans in general
don't care about consumers,
they care about corporate profit.
And so, Republicans in
general have not been in favor
of strong grantee trust laws,
but rather weak grantee trust laws.
And that's in fact why
we are where we are,
but Republicans do value
small business, okay.
And when you look at
corporate profits in America,
what you see is a whitening,
it's like income inequality
only for corporations.
The money is all going to the biggest
four or five platforms really.
If you think about the ones
that everybody talks about,
Google, Facebook Apple, Amazon,
that's where all the money is.
So, the small business
coalition runs from,
AT and T and Comcast,
and John Deere all the way
down to the corner coffee shop.
All of those parties would like to,
preserve their own profits,
and not give them to Google.
And so, they are willing
to ally with the consumers,
to have stronger antitrust laws,
and those corporations have
senators and representatives.
So, it is possible I think,
that we will get a antitrust reform soon.
And what would that
antitrust reform look like?
It would change the burden
of proof in more settings.
That is to say, if two
corporations want to merge,
rather than the government
needing to prove
that that's harmful,
we would make the corporations
prove that it's fine, okay.
And what that does is
it just lowers the cost,
to enforce the law because
the government can,
doesn't have to spend as much money
or time or resources to
figure out what's best to do.
It increases the budgets of the agencies.
The draft laws would repudiate,
explicitly repudiate cases that
courts got wrong in the past
where that allowed market power to build
that protected monopolies,
and a big area of interest
for economists and lawyers,
both in this space is
protecting competition
when nascent or potential competitors
are excluded or bought.
So, think about Facebook and Instagram,
or any setting where the
rival isn't yet really fully
in the market, but is coming,
and the action of the
dominant firm is to buy them,
or to exclude them.
We want to try to protect competition
in those cases where
oftentimes the benefit
to consumers is innovation.
It's not so much price,
but it's about a new competitor entering
and doing something in a different way.
So, that's what I expect to happen.
What should happen, is an
additional step beyond antitrust.
So, if you think what happened
between October and December of 2020,
there were five or six
enormous antitrust cases
that were filed by government plaintiffs.
We had the house report
on digital platforms
early in the fall as I mentioned,
then the Department of Justice
and some States sued Google
over it search monopoly,
Texas and some other States
sued Google over ad tech,
the FTC and some States sued Facebook,
for its monopoly position.
So, that was all very exciting,
we caught up to Europe
after 10 years of delay,
and everybody said, wow, we've done it.
Now, the problem is that
once we come out of COVID,
and insurrection,
then we start to pay
attention to this again,
we're gonna notice that the
first hearing in these case,
is September 2023, okay.
That we're gonna have the case,
then we're gonna have to wait
for the judge to write an opinion,
then there'll be an
appeal and we have to wait
for that to be scheduled
and we have to brief it.
And then we have a
remedy stage at the end,
and all in all this is
gonna take a long time.
And I think citizens and the affirmation
mentioned small businesses,
are not gonna wanna wait that long,
and they're gonna want to regulate.
Europe in December 15th,
released draft regulations
to control digital platforms,
once again, lapping the United States,
but we can watch those and react to them,
and I think it's not
gonna take us 10 years,
to pass some digital platform regulation.
Again, the same coalition, the consumers,
and small businesses,
and the things that we ought
to put in that regulation are,
much, much more consumer protection,
which we really don't have online.
So, what kinds of
buttons can be pre-ticked
when you go on a site?
Buttons that make you buy
things and subscribe to things,
and share your data, which
you didn't plan to do,
but the buttons are pre-ticked.
What about auto renewals?
What about terms and conditions
that are 50 pages long,
and just legally written the end,
nobody understands them,
and it could say give away
your first born in there
and you would still click, I agree.
What about uses for my data
that I don't fully understand
and that are vague and maybe
actually aren't even adhered to
by the platform that's
claiming they do that.
There's other issues like interoperability
between businesses.
So, for example, when I send email
from the Yale ISP to the, to
somebody on Gmail or Hotmail,
or at Harvard, it arrives.
And that is because
email is interoperable.
Well, there are lots of digital platforms
that are not interoperable,
and that is a problem,
because then I'm stuck
inside that platform,
and I can't communicate outside of it.
And that gives the platform
a lot of market power.
So, interoperability would tremendously
increase competition.
And then the third thing that should go,
I mean, there's lots of things
you could put in this regulation,
but I'm just gonna highlight
three of them for you.
A third one I think is
really important is,
thinking about the split of the
surplus between the platform
and the everybody else, the
small businesses and the users.
And that goes to some extent
to the bargaining power
of those users and small businesses,
because they don't have
anywhere else to go,
because it's a monopoly.
So, that's one way that this arises,
but the other way is maybe
we should give businesses,
and people property
rights over their data,
so, that they can extract
something from the platform,
for sharing it.
Or the platform doesn't
get to use it for free,
but has to actually talk to them about,
whether they, what they
would like to be paid,
for that data.
Or for example, should
businesses be allowed to use,
the features of the operating
system or the platform,
that the platforms own applications use?
So, the platforms have
access to certain APIs
or functionality,
should the competing
applications on the platform,
also have access to those
APIs or functionality,
that would be something
else regulation could do.
So, those kinds of things
go into regulation.
It's a sort of a pro
competitive, pro consumer,
type of thing I have in mind.
And I think, again,
there's a broad coalition
that would like this.
You need legislation to pass that,
and you also probably need a new agency.
A regulator that is designed to look
after digital platforms,
and that has a consumer
protection element,
a competition element,
and some special expertise
in digital businesses.
Which by the way, will
be nearly everything,
when you think about the
fact that stop and shop,
is delivering me groceries,
by letting me order over the internet.
So, this is a very big remit
and it needs to be done well
but I think it is important
to move forward on.
- Okay, thank you all very much.
That was really interesting
and great perspectives,
on three really important
areas of public policy.
Do any of the panelists have any questions
or comments inspired by your
colleagues presentations?
- Well, I have a question that echoes
one that was asked in the Q
and A that I can see here,
from the attendees which is to Fiona,
which is just what you think,
if anything is gonna take place
in the healthcare antitrust arena?
- I think that there'll
be vigorous enforcement,
relative to the last four years.
And that might show up,
if you give the FTC more money,
that will show up in pharma,
that will show up in hospitals
and hospital mergers,
that might actually appear also
a little bit in regulations,
that have up til now
actually protected incumbents
from competition instead
of exposing incumbents
to competition.
So, I don't think it's
gonna do what your remarks
talked about, Jacob,
which is really giving you no
more access to more people,
but every little bit counts.
And the more market
power every doctor group,
or hospital group or drug
has means that especially,
as we see insurers and employers
shifting more of the costs
directly on to enrollees,
they're going out and paying
these out-of-pocket prices,
that keep climbing.
So, I think it is an important
way to help regular citizens
by lowering those costs.
- Thanks.
- Good, any other comments from panelists,
regarding the presentations.
- I just think I'm not
the political scientist,
I'm just the economist,
but I do have to say that
it seems to me that voting,
and voting rights is the
way that you build power.
I mean, if you're gonna
do what Phil wants to do,
and what Jacob wants to do,
you have to elect representatives
that also want to do that.
And if most people in the
country want these things,
which I think is true,
then we need to make our
elected representatives,
reflect those preferences.
Which means that really
the only thing that matters
in the next two years is voting rights.
- Yeah, I mean, I would just
say that the legislation
that probably most of the
attendees are aware of,
that would address these issues is HR one,
or S one in the Senate,
and of course, the numbers
is symbolic of this priority,
that's placed on it by the
congressional leadership,
if not the by new administration.
And I would just,
I won't go into the
specifics of those bill.
I did a big podcast for deconstructed,
which is kind of progressive
podcast if you're interested,
but I will say that I
proposed my earlier comments,
about the filibuster that by
far the most likely scenario,
under which the filibuster falls,
is that particularly the
voting rights portion of that
which is now bears the imprimatur
of the great late John Lewis,
that that becomes the
subject of a filibuster,
that is broken by Democrats
to pass voting reform,
the question mark there,
and of course it would also,
not just bear the
imprimatur of John Lewis,
but carry with it the
passion of the movements,
that Phil was talking about.
But the question mark there is,
not just whether that would happen,
and it would require
a really serious push,
by the bi-administration
which so far has been a little bit,
wary of declaring itself fully committed,
to pushing this as its core priority,
despite the fact that it's high
in the congressional agenda
but it would also,
it also raises a question
whether some kind
of specific carve-out would be
engineered to the filibuster
for voting rights legislation
that wouldn't apply,
to things like the public option.
Which by the way,
could be done through
reconciliation as I said.
But even then may not be
able to get the votes,
of the Holy Trinity of moderate
Democrats seminar, tester,
and mansion.
So, what was I gonna say?
Oh, so, one last sort of
point on filibuster reform,
which is I think kind of interest,
to those in the audience,
because it is so fundamental
to all of the issues
we've talked about here,
is that there is also a push
for kind of alternatives
to the filibuster that
wouldn't go all the way
to a pure majority rule.
So, if people aren't sure
we can talk about those,
but they might involve like restoring
the talking filibuster,
where senators would actually
have to stay on the floor,
rather than being able to
move on to other business.
Honestly values.
- Can I just say, especially
for those 86-year-old senators.
- No bathroom breaks.
Okay, but anyway, I'll stop there.
- Great, thanks a lot, Jacob.
Phil, do you have anything
you'd like to say,
in response to Fiona,
- Yeah, I was about to jump in.
- As an opportunity maybe to elaborate,
when you were saying that,
you hope that the pressure stays on,
tell me if you could just elaborate,
what is can you unpack
that a little bit as well?
- So, I find it's interesting
Fiona the framing that,
sort of voting rights above all else,
because without people who
are sympathetic to this,
we don't get any other things done.
There's a part of me, both
in my brain and in my life,
that is committed to
that understanding of it.
And yet also, I don't think
anyone who was elected
to federal office prior to May 25th,
would have been discussing
police abolition,
without the movements
that are outside of this.
So, sometimes it's the case,
that what you want, if
you wanna get the better
of two or three or four options,
into the elected seat,
but sometimes you just need
to change the conditions
on the ground to make it unreasonable,
that there wouldn't be a
movement going forward.
You had Republicans in the
Senate judiciary hearing,
on issues of policing,
calling folks like me
to come talk to them,
about racism in policing,
an area that's not their issue,
but you couldn't see what was happening
across the United States
and the public protests
in Thailand, right?
Call the science and say
Black Lives Matter and say,
we should do nothing.
So, my hope is that,
the kind of engagement,
and activism that was spawned,
both of being locked inside,
for those first couple of months,
and of seeing a world that
doesn't look like our values,
playing out on the streets,
of what does look like our communities,
I'm hoping that engagement
stays up, right?
So, it's the case that because
I get to teach undergraduates
and I occasionally talk
with high school students,
I deal with not only people who
have a lot more hair than me
but people with a lot more energy,
and a lot more devotion to these issues.
I have not seen in my adult life,
the level, not just a
political engagement,
but a political
sophistication and education,
and the desire to take a long form view.
So, what I mean Alan, to
keeping the pressure on,
when Obama was leaving office, he said,
you guys could have pushed
me to do more, right.
And there's the famous bit both FDR,
there's a version of
FDR doing and LBJ doing,
of like, I agree with you
now, go make me do it, right.
It's after you are first, right.
But the idea is that,
it's possible to move the
center of political will,
outside of the electoral process.
And I think it's really
important to name that,
because in the communities where I work,
there are lots of folks who feel like,
the game's already rigged.
There's nobody who's gonna
be passing any legislation
that speaks to their issues,
that make their lives easier,
that make it more likely
that their proximity of the
American dream gets any closer.
But I do know how to take to the streets,
I do know how to write a sign.
And the more we have folks
who are able to speak to them
the less that's necessary,
the more they engage in
those kinds of extra partisan
behaviors, right,
the more we're gonna
get people who are gonna
be stuck closer to them.
So, my hope is that we get
significantly more of that.
And at the same time that
we're expanding voting rights,
we have folks who
understand that elections,
are not the only kind of
politics in the country.
- Good.
- Separate from that,
can I pivot and ask a
question back to the panel
as we move through?
- Yeah, of course.
- Every time I listen to
my brilliant colleagues
in other areas,
I'm so eager to just go and take classes
and also to be the selfish
person in the class who says,
how does that relate to my thing?
'Cause I'm thinking increasingly about,
the social determinants of safety.
The way we talk about the
social determinants of health.
There isn't a science of this.
We're trying to build it up,
because we were just not invested,
but I'm interested both
from Jacob and Fiona,
if you guys can talk about the
ways that you see synergies
across the federal government,
in what you're doing.
'Cause when I talk about a reckoning,
I talked about DOJ looking back,
but it's also HUD that
needs to look back, right?
And it's absolutely like
when we're talking about,
privacy and surveillance,
we're gonna have to talk about antitrust.
So, in all of the areas where
you guys have expertise,
they're not even two degrees removed,
from the spaces that if we
do things before policing,
to take care of public safety,
we're going to need to talk.
But part our blockages,
the obstacles is that,
these issue areas become
silos within government,
and there's not been conversation.
So, in this summer have
something different for everyone,
I'm wondering the degree to
which you've been able to talk
to folks in other areas,
about what you feel like
needs to move forward,
and the ways in which we
can start to break down,
some of those silos to
get more accomplished.
- I have one answer.
At the Thurman Arnold Project,
we had a conference
halfway through January,
which you can go look up on the web,
entitled antitrust and
big AG, big agriculture.
And one of the things
that is just astonishing,
I knew relatively little about agriculture
before we started down this path,
the conference was run
organized primarily,
by my deputy Austin Ferric.
And when you go and look at
the problems in rural America,
not only do we have
incredible market power,
by slaughterhouses and meat packers,
and the guys who buy the beef and the lamb
and sell the tractors and the grain,
Monsanto and John Deere and so on,
who are they employing?
They're employing black and
brown workers, immigrants,
they're not paying them,
the working conditions are terrible.
Why is that?
Because they have monopsony power.
They're the only employer in the town,
not only are the only seller of meat.
So, the meat price is high,
the wages are low,
the environmental
degradation is really high.
The rural community is then hollowed out,
because the jobs are poor
and the air quality is awful.
The animals are unhappy
and badly cared for.
So, it's a confluence of places
where you don't wanna look at it,
just as the Department of Agriculture,
or the Department of Justice or the EPA.
You want to say all of these
things are going wrong,
in these rural communities
at the same time.
And if we went in and we looked
at how concentrated they are,
and we tried to make there
be more choice for employers,
if there were an environmental regulation
that limited the size of hog farms,
that would reduce air pollution,
it would create more
employers for the workers,
it would improve the lives of the animals.
I mean, just everything,
it's like one bird and sorry,
one stone and eight birds.
And that's a place where I think,
the silos need to break down.
- And I wanna jump,
I wanna get to the questions
but let me just say the
obvious Phil which is that,
we're not talking about
healthcare the same way we were
before the pandemic or before
the protests of the summer.
The degree to which we, people
who are on the front lines
thinking through healthcare
are having to confront
the profound racial inequities,
and class inequities that
are embedded in the system,
that would not be fixed,
were by conventional
reforms if we were not,
if we don't confront those
inequities frontally,
that is just a sea change
in thinking that I think,
in the longterm will
deliver a lot of good.
Unfortunately, in the near term,
this has just been a
heartbreaking reminder.
This period has been a
heartbreaking reminder,
of how HUN finished that the
agenda of systemic reform.
And it really is.
So, that would be my quick answer.
- Okay, good.
All right, thank you.
Those are really extremely
interesting remarks.
Let me turn now to some of the questions,
that our audience has been has asked
and is continuing to ask.
I'm just gonna sorta read a few of them,
and then get some answers
from the panelist.
Phil, there was a question for you,
that like I'm having trouble finding,
but it was a very specific question about,
so, suppose you were to
reduce the money spent
on the police force and redirected
into some community spending,
with an effort to improve
the quality of life
in the effected communities,
what would be the best way in your view,
to spend that money for that purpose?
And I don't know if you have
any thoughts about that.
I know you've been very involved
in some of these efforts.
- Yeah, you can't find it,
'cause I typed an answer,
so, it showed up in the answer section.
No, but it's okay.
I'm very happy to speak
a portion of it as well.
It's a great question.
I have been thinking a great deal about,
how do we do redesign instead
of just re-imagining this.
At some point you got to
actually do some things,
'cause there's bodies souling.
And I think it also goes to,
there was another question
in the chat about,
the trade-off between short term reforms,
getting what you can,
and the longer term of getting
to where we need to go.
I'll say that I have
been in a bunch of spaces
where mayors and governors
and State reps are saying,
we don't know how to get
from here to a smaller,
a police force size.
We don't know how to
get from here to better.
So, we need a bunch of
research before we move.
Now, I'm a scientist, right?
I'm in favor of more research,
that nobody who wants more data
on public safety than I do.
I swear I would challenge
any of you to fight on it.
But that's not to say we
need to do the science first.
Sometimes, the science
has to come afterwards.
And there are literally
thousands of natural experiments,
happening all over the country right now.
I don't know what the right
percentage of budget is,
to take away from law enforcement,
and put into mental health
versus substance abuse,
versus child welfare
versus green greenspaces,
versus food insecurity.
I know that each of those things
are really good predictors
of safety and of police
intervention later on.
And so, the more money you've
got in social services,
particularly for mental
health and substance abuse,
the less likely you are to be calling 911.
And in cities like San Francisco
and Oakland and Austin,
where they have,
and Houston now where
they've taken law enforcement
and segregated out the
mental health response.
So, it's just social workers.
You're seeing a two
and three and in Austin
a four X response to 911.
911 calls go up four
times on certain weekends,
just because they know they can get
a mental health response.
That suggests a huge under utilization
of mental health resources,
which is an unintended
insight of this moment,
where we're having this
reckoning with policing.
But the long and short is,
we don't know exactly how much,
so what we should be doing
is a longterm investment
in science,
so that all of these natural experiments,
are yielding information some insights,
into how we think about scaling.
And to the person who
asked about short-term
versus long-term.
I know that Jacob and Fiona
have things to say about it,
and I wanna be out of the
way so they can answer.
But in the context of
policing, it is often the case.
Well, we can't get to that,
so, let's do this small thing,
has been the way that movements
and requests for progress die.
The real answer to this I think is,
we have to have a shared
idea about where we're going.
That way if I'm saying we want
to abolish the death penalty
that's not in the way
of shrinking the size of law enforcement.
And if we're saying, we
wanna give feedback back,
on racial equity and police behavior,
that's not in the way.
There even some trainings
that are not in the way,
provided they don't create
a whole economic system,
that feeds the beast of unions,
and out of control growth
in law enforcement.
But without that shared understanding
of where we're going
without the roadmap, right,
my what we can get now is in the way
of someone else's revolution.
And too often,
when we're trying to combine
movements with science,
smart policy to try and
save people's lives,
with a broader sense of
what democracy can be,
that's where we end up
cannibalizing each other,
and getting absolutely nothing,
which by the way is what
it feels like we got,
each and every single time we've
had a reckoning on policing
prior to that, what we
got for Michael Brown Jr,
what we got for Rodney King,
what we got in 1968,
what we got after Tulsa.
- Good, thank you, Phil.
Let me ask Jacob a question,
Jacob, what would you say,
so, I can certainly imagine,
and I I heard your arguments for why,
it's a moral imperative to
expand the healthcare coverage.
I find those very compelling personally,
what would you say is the
best argument against,
the public option?
So, as this debate unfolds,
what do you anticipate?
I mean, not what will be,
I mean I guess I could ask
you what arguments you think
will be made against it when it comes up,
but what do you think of as some of,
what are the arguments against it,
that you caused you to pause at all?
Are any of them reasonable
in your view or?
- Yeah, no, I mean, look, if
I wouldn't be a good academic
if I wasn't racked with self-doubt right.
So, no, I mean, I recognize
that the public option
is not to be all end all
of healthcare reform,
but I think that,
and let me just say about
what I consider to be the kind
of important developments
and thinking about
the public option that have taken place
since the idea first emerged
on the public agenda,
during the debate over the
Affordable Care Act in 2009, 10.
So, during that discussion,
I think the public option was seen as,
mostly a kind of tacked on addition
to a reform framework that
mostly followed the model
that had been passed in
Massachusetts, right?
Where people would have
access to private insurance,
and that would be regulated.
And the trade off was essentially,
or the bargain was essentially,
that the insurance companies
would essentially agree
to be regulated and not
be able to discriminate
against unhealthy patients
or charge them higher rates,
in return they would basically
get a bundle of money,
from government and to
provide that coverage,
and the forces of kind of competition,
choosing among these plans,
would basically bring down costs,
for that coverage over time.
It was seen as ancillary
to a fundamentally
employment-based system.
And so, that was never my vision,
but that was really
where it was in 2009, 10.
And if you look at where it's gone,
and I think if you put a
public option into that system,
it's basically, it's very likely
to get marginalized, right?
And so, where the debate is,
where I think the debate has gone
and needs to continue to go,
is the idea that the
public insurance option,
should be something quite distinct
from private insurance plans.
It should be modeled after Medicare.
It should be public in the sense that,
it's pulling the risks with
the federal government,
essentially managing it
and paying the costs.
It should have a broad
access to providers,
and it should use regulated payment rates.
And that it should be
something that is available,
not just to those who don't
have coverage to their employer
but to those who have
coverage from their employer,
that doesn't provide adequate protection.
And so, in that world, I
think the public option,
has a lot more transformative potential.
I mean, on one side, you'll
have critics conservative saying
it's gonna be a slippery
slope to universal Medicare
on the end.
And many advocates might
think that as well.
And on the other side,
you're gonna have Medicare
for all advocates saying,
if you have that system it's
not gonna be robust enough
to be able to provide
the kind of protection
that citizens need,
that you could get through
a universal system,
and the insurance
companies have figured out,
how to game Medicare, they'll
figure out how to game it.
And to me, so, that's I think the vision
has really evolved quite a bit,
into something where the
public option would be seen
as something universally
available nationwide,
to everyone regardless of
whether they had coverage,
through another source,
and that would be built
on a public platform.
But I do think there
are real risks even then
because and Fiona knows this well,
the fundamental reality is
that if we don't figure out
how to provide coverage affordably, right?
Any platform we build,
isn't gonna be sustainable.
And that's the path we're on today.
It's the path we've been on.
And I still think there's
not enough guarantee,
in current models to be
able to really provide
that kind of coverage on
generous terms over time.
And so, to me, that's where a lot of
the most significant thinking
is gonna need to take place.
And one thing the pandemic I think
has really driven home is that,
is it like a lot of the
things we took for granted
about what works in healthcare,
are pretty fragile and the
kind of the models of payment,
and delivery of care that we have,
that have developed the United States,
can produce deeply,
well, it can produce
really wonderful outcomes
produced deeply perverse ones as well.
And so, to me, that's gonna
be the sort of next frontier,
of thinking about the public option.
- Great, thanks very much.
That's very interesting Jacob.
A question that I'd like to send to Fiona,
a question on the questionnaire
asks you to comment
on the Facebook oversight
board as a protector
for consumers, rather than
an obstacle for competitors.
And let me just pivot on that
a little bit and just say,
what do you think about the general idea,
of self-regulation by these large tech,
by these tech giants says as
a regulatory strategy to you?
'Cause that seems to be at least,
I think that's sort of the
impulse I think of that,
Facebook Supreme Court, I
guess is that they've set up.
- Well, many decades, perhaps centuries,
companies have been in
favor of self regulation,
and we know why, because it doesn't work.
I mean, if you have a
profit incentive to engage
in a certain behavior
that harms consumers,
saying you promise not to do it,
is not gonna be a very full-proof way
of getting that outcome.
So, I think in all seriousness,
this is a terrible idea
and it never works.
And if societies want certain outcomes,
then they should codify them
in law and make a regulator,
and be serious about holding companies
to the standards of
behavior that they want.
I think when people ask me about,
difficult first amendment
questions and speech
and censorship and whatever
about the digital platforms,
my usual answer is to say
that's not my area of expertise,
go see professor Jack
Balkan at the law school,
but also, boy wouldn't it be nice,
if I could change my social network,
when I didn't like what it was doing.
I have a newspaper, if I don't,
if I decided I didn't like
the content of my newspaper,
I will subscribed to
a different newspaper.
The problem that we have with a lot
of these digital platforms,
is there isn't another choice.
So, I feel like if we
could get the antitrust,
and the competition
policy and the regulation
and the entry barriers to work better,
so, there was more entry
and more competition
and therefore more choices,
that the fraught question of
how to regulate the content
of the platform would become lessened,
because people would
simply vote with their feet
and go somewhere else.
And there would still be issues,
but many many people
wouldn't feel as frustrated,
because they would be able to move
to a place that was giving
them what they wanted.
- Fiona another question I
just wanted to throw to you,
about regulating the tech companies.
Well, I'll read the question,
information technologies
do not map to classical,
antitrust conception of bundled products
information in its collection,
permits the creation of services,
that are simply not
available to small startups,
in particular, the social
graph like the human genome
is a feature of the natural world.
It has been permitted to
be proprietarily owned.
How would should antitrust
law address this powerful
inherent feature of an
information economy?
I'll also add to this, that
some of these companies might be
because of network issues,
natural monopolies,
rather than the kinds
of industries that are,
you have like a classical competition,
of a bunch of small firms.
How does that affect your perspective
toward regulation in these markets?
- Yeah, there are ways to
deal with this problem.
The first is to change
laws and regulations,
to affect the property rights of the data.
Right now, it's really not
clear what belongs to me
in terms of my data, what I can control,
how I can control it,
the same with a business.
If that business finds
me through a platform,
does that business have a right
to know something about me
or can the platform keep
it all and withhold it
from the business?
To how much do I share and
does the business have a right
to sell onto others or
to use it internally,
in other totally unrelated activities,
that happened to be under
the same corporate umbrella.
So, there's a whole set
of what I might call
consumer protection kinds
of issues around data,
that would be very helpful
if we had more laws
and regulations around.
The second issue of the
network effects issue,
comes back to interoperability
which I mentioned earlier,
the internet is a giant
network of email traffic,
where all of us have an ISP that had,
that where that's our home,
and we can write to each other.
And we can write to
anybody who has an eye,
who's on an ISP that conforms
to the internet protocol.
That is not true, if we
think about Facebook,
that is not true, if we think about,
proprietary social networks.
There's no reason why we as a society,
can't decide that social
networks should be interoperable.
Just the same way email
and telephones are,
I have an AT and T phone, it
can call your Verizon phone.
Why is that? Because it's a rule.
And we could have those same rules,
for other businesses also.
And once you have that rule,
then it doesn't matter how
big your social network is,
because the users of it can communicate
with everybody else on
other social networks.
Just like I can have a very tiny ISP,
and it's on the internet
communicating with,
emailing everybody else.
So, this is a very simple idea,
we've used it before, and it
gets rid of entry barriers,
that are driven by network effects.
- Thanks, I've actually
never heard that idea before.
That's actually a really good idea.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, Fiona.
Jacob, so, moving back around
the panel in reverse order,
Jacob you mentioned cost control measures,
a question it was asked,
what's your favorite cost
control measure for medical care?
- Well, I like them all to be honest.
I mean, I really don't think,
I really don't to use the cliche, right?
I'm a belt and suspenders kind of guy,
when it comes to cost control,
we're have to do a lot
of different things.
Let me mention three, one
which is very conventional,
one that's kind of a
little more out there,
and I think links up with
some of what Fiona said,
and a third that's I'll keep you guessing,
and I'll do this quickly.
So, the first is like
when prices are too high,
is not a bad idea in the
context of distorted markets
like healthcare to try to control prices.
So, that, I mean, that has
been a really key part,
of how other countries have
dealt with medical costs,
and it should be a key
part of how we do it.
And it doesn't have to be that
you're dictating the price,
you could start by just
simply having a level
above which prices cannot go.
I mean, one of the nice
features of the legislation,
that Fiona helped with
on surprise medical bills
was simply just saying,
we're not gonna say that
it has to be the price X,
but it cannot be higher than Y.
And because people don't have any ability
to decide in advance that
they're gonna get these
surprise medical bills
and therefore to choose
what the prices will be.
So, I've often thought that,
in addition to a public option,
we should have basically
a price ceiling outside
of the public option,
that is based on the public option prices
but is a multiple of them
and is moving downwards.
That's, so, price, I'm not
saying that we should have
fee for service medicine forever,
but we have a lot of fee
for service medicine,
we should put caps on prices.
It's what every other country does.
So, the second thing is
actually relates to the,
to something that Fiona was alluding to,
which is the enormous
amount of public investment,
that goes into and public
support that goes into,
a lot of the basic medical
goods that we enjoy, right?
So, pharmaceuticals are a key example.
So, in addition to like
thinking about antitrust,
I think the flip side of that
is thinking about patents,
and about intellectual
property in a different way.
And the vaccine development
process I think,
that we just went through really
highlights the issue here, right?
If it absolutely makes sense,
we should be pouring billions
and billions and billions,
hundreds of billions of dollars,
in developing a vaccine for COVID-19.
It doesn't make a whole lot of sense,
that then the pricing should
be entirely determined
by private companies,
who in this context may behave
in a very responsible way,
but in general, the system
is really screwed up.
So, that is a big deal,
and it's going to be a
bigger deal going forward
as biotechnological innovation.
So, I put that there.
So, the really the last kind
of idea out there that I think,
is really kind of Goffian
given what we've said,
is that I used to scoff a
little bit of this idea that,
oh, we should be really
thinking a lot about,
all the other things
that affect health care.
You just can't see what's
happening before us right now,
or the changes in health
that are occurring
among key populations without recognizing,
that we're spending in
really bad ways often.
We're paying it for a
really expensive acute care
especially at end of life,
and we should be investing a lot more.
And just like when we're
thinking about policing,
well, should we be trying to deal
with these problems at the back end?
Or should we be doing more
investment on the front end?
Or should we be thinking about
also alternative modalities
for dealing with the
problems at the back end,
should be dealing with mental health,
as opposed to with
criminal criminal justice?
I feel like in healthcare,
we haven't done nearly enough of that.
Well, it's a lot of
times paid lip service,
and a lot of the stuff that we
pay lip service to is stupid.
Like, we need more wellness
programs in the workplace.
Like, that's fine, but
it's not the big thing.
The big thing is there a huge
pockets of American society,
whose health suffering, because
we've seen rampant racism,
or an opioid epidemic that's
due to the destruction
of jobs and opportunity and
key parts of the country.
And we're not gonna deal
with their healthcare prices,
if we don't start to
think much more about,
what is the pipeline that
is producing the problems,
that we are dealing with down the road.
- Okay, Jacob let me pick up on that.
- Yeah, thanks a lot.
- On the third point and turn to Phil,
and just say Phil and Jacob is,
was alluding to some of the root causes,
in your description of
the policing issues.
You were also talking
about social determinants,
and I wanted to know if you have anything
you'd like to share on
how the educational system
contributes to this or could,
do you have any ideas for,
how the educational system could be,
used to help address
some of these problems?
Do you have any views about the quality
of the educational system
that people experience?
- Yeah, I mean, so, one of
the ways that I've found
to be newly annoying of late,
is to ask the question back
to everyone, which one?
So, when you say the
education system, which one?
Are we talking about higher education?
My hope is that I am currently
warping the minds of,
150 some undergraduates, graduate,
and professional school students,
to get them to think about some
of these issues differently.
I imagine that you were talking about
the primary education system.
Don't worry, I'm gonna answer it tomorrow.
In which is, I said, okay then which one?
Because in several of
the cities where we work,
because of the reaction
against integration,
they have private schools
that are so dirt cheap,
in majority white neighborhoods,
that they functionally have
reproduced segregation,
which is why Nikole Hannah Jones finds,
essentially, we've got
schools that are just everest,
not more segregated than they were
before brown vs board of education.
Good job, all deliberate speed.
So, I think we have to
think about what we mean,
by education and what
role we want it to play.
That said, I've been shocked.
I mean, Alan, I've been working with,
increasingly complex models,
for how we predict racial disparities,
and where the variants
lives in those ratios.
I'm shocked by how much primary education,
doesn't soak up variants.
Once you start looking at just basically,
race, poverty and and sort of crime
as if it's not already baked in.
But there's good research that suggests,
the longer kids are in school
literally during the day,
and the more time they're in school
over the course of the summer,
the less likely they are to get involved
in petty crimes, right?
So, you could make an argument that,
if we made schools better caretakers
of particularly adolescent children,
that we could put a
debt in the crime rates.
I'd also though go back to this and say,
if the way that we deal
with adolescents acting out,
is punishing them with
handcuffs and cages,
maybe the problem wasn't
the kids in the first place,
but that we imagined that something about
normal adolescent
development was criminal.
So, there are absolutely
ways that it seems like,
increasing coverage and resources,
for schools can make a debt,
particularly adolescent crime rates.
But that's only within
context where we've taken
for granted, that it's
okay to criminalize,
what absolutely is a criminal
and more affluent neighborhoods.
Or at least it seems that way.
The trade-off between the two,
like we have more control,
over public education in
vulnerable communities.
So, more resources and
more counseling there,
I mean, we have literally
tens of thousands
of jurisdictions that have no counselors,
but hundreds of law
enforcement in the schools.
So, for sure more resources,
we could make a debt.
And I'm in favor of doing that,
of creating the social
services and expanded hours,
and capacity for primary education
in vulnerable communities.
But the longterm solve of this I think,
is solving the problem of
what is, and isn't punishable,
were punishment worthy,
in the communities where we've
given them fewer options.
And that I think is
likely not gonna be a job,
that primary education can do.
Hopefully, it's a job
that folks who graduate,
from secondary education will do
as they move into positions of power.
- Great, Phil, thank you so much.
So, we're coming up to the end of our time
and I'd like to turn to the
panelists and ask them for,
if they have any final
concluding thoughts.
And I also would like if
they would like to of course,
if you could recommend something you read,
that gives you a special,
that you think is especially
insightful in your policy area,
a blog or someone you follow,
that you think is really on target,
that you would recommend to the audience,
and then I would also say,
is there someone who's
on the other side of the
issues that from you,
just buy somewhat God knows why,
but it just always seems like this person,
Cathy disagrees with me for some reason,
like every time she has a position
it's always on the other side,
but yet you learn
something from that person.
So, someone who is both,
both someone who you
who resonates with you,
as well as someone who
might be on the other side,
that you would recommend
as a place to turn,
for other perspectives
that you find valuable.
So, I'll go,
if we could go Phil, then
Jacob, and then Fiona.
- Man, all right.
For the person I would read,
there's a young blogger,
and data visualization person
who I think is phenomenal.
His name is W.E.B Du Bois,
I highly recommend he's
got a number of books out,
I'm being mildly facetious.
When I talk with Phil
Agnew, who's an activist
who came popularity after
the Trayvon Martin shooting,
or when I'm talking with Eve Ewing
who is a poet and a scholar at Chicago,
I come back, they come back
to Du Bois as often as I do.
So, as much as I would love to talk
about the young people who I follow,
who are fantastic, like
Phil Agnew, like Eve Ewing,
I would say if you really
want to be involved
in what the cutting edge is,
and what's gonna be five years from now,
go back and read "Dusk and Dawn,"
go back and read "Black
Reconstruction" by DuBois.
Because all of the folks who I am teaching
and who I am learning from,
of the generation being younger than me,
that's what they're doing.
In terms of the people
who are on the other side
of these things,
Alan, I'm such a
contrarian about this stuff
that I'm gonna be difficult also
because I didn't have as
much time to think about,
who it would be.
I am of a mind that there
shouldn't be sides on this,
and it's not a cop out and
I'll explain to you why.
The folks who were calling
the sort of most died
in the war abolitionists,
in the space of policing
agree about 90 to 95%,
and their demands with law
enforcement executives.
The place where they don't agree,
is how much those law
enforcement executives
should get paid,
and that's a serious disagreement.
But the folks who were on the
other side of no policing,
should only get bigger,
are not people that the
executives take seriously,
nor the activists take seriously.
So, I'd say actually the
one bit of good news,
is that while there's
lots of tension, right?
Because the theories and
diagnoses that we have,
are being used to put, be put intention.
The demands are actually
quite a great deal aligned.
And because we also align on the fact
that we don't know where we're going,
much less how are we gonna get there,
there is increasingly a necessary humility
within this space.
So, I would say Kat Brooks
is a person you can talk to,
you can follow who's tweeting right now,
and it was at the Oakland
Police Terrorism Network,
is a great place to go
for that kind of stuff.
But I don't think it's
because there's disagreement,
I think it's because there's
synergy and spirited debate
on how we frame and
what we go after first.
- Terrific, thank you so much, Phil.
And thank you for all of your
comments during today's panel.
Jacob.
- Yeah, so, to keep it really brief,
I mean, I don't think there's
a single source on healthcare
that there are a lot
of different resources,
that people can turn to,
the three places that I find
myself turning the most,
when I just want to
like kind of figure out
what's going on in the
present or health affairs,
which is a well-known journal,
the Kaiser Health Network,
and Kaiser Family Foundation Sites,
which are sort of like the one-stop,
so, for a lot of this stuff.
And then the data journalism done on Vox,
which is now probably moving to,
with as recline over to New York Times.
So, those are the three
places I tend to rely
for just sort of what's
happening in the policy weeds.
So, I'm gonna be contrarian
a little bit contrarian to,
which is to say that, like,
I've had a lot of fights,
with the right over the public option,
and I don't find myself
particularly convinced.
And so, and I feel like a
lot, like it's very revealing,
that the people who remain on
the hard right on healthcare
who are the ones who help
design say the repeal
and replace legislation
that didn't happen in 2017,
did they become increasingly removed,
not just from the ideas I support,
but from the ideas they want supported.
Like the mandatory private
health insurance model.
So, like Stuart, I'm a
big fan of Stuart Butler,
who used to be at the Heritage Foundation,
now he's at the Brookings Institution,
so, I can't say that
these are conservative.
But on that side, on the left,
I mean they come after me,
right, no pun intended,
right and left.
And on the left,
I really liked Jerry Freeman
at Amherst, UMass Amherst.
She's been writing a lot
about Medicare for all lately.
Don't always agree with them,
but he worked a lot with Bernie Sanders,
and he has some interesting
recent writings.
He has a new book, which
I had near me lately,
which is making the case
for Medicare for all.
- Terrific, thank you very much, Jacob.
And again, thank you
for all of your comments
and participation in tonight's panel.
And now, to wrap up, I
guess, a Fiona Scott Morton.
- I just wanna second what Jacob said.
I will say that the reason that repeal
and replace never got a replace,
is because the Affordable
Care Act was a comp
was supposed to be, was
a Republican proposal.
It's Romneycare.
It's outsourcing government
provided health insurance,
to the private sector.
So, if you want, if you're
not gonna support that,
you're left with just letting people die,
which has been the default
alternative on the right.
So, there really isn't
anybody to argue with.
It's kind of like it's either,
the Affordable Care Act
or move left from that.
So, that's a problem for the
intellectual debate there.
So, what do I follow
that I think is great.
There's a blog run by
the Washington Center
for Equitable Growth
called Competitive Edge,
which has really nice anti-trust analysis
and competition topics.
Slightly broader covering
more regulatory topics,
as well as anti-trust is the blog
at the University of Chicago,
Booth School of Business
called Pro Market,
run by Luigi Zingales.
And that's a great source
of really fun topics,
and both easy to read and very accessible.
Yeah, I have to answer your
second question for me.
In my field the other side to the people
who want competition are the
people want corporate profits.
If you do the economic analysis, right,
you maximize social
welfare with competition.
So, there isn't an economist
who doesn't think that's true.
And so, the other side of
this debate are the folks
who want corporate profits there,
corporations obviously,
the people they pay to do scholarship,
or that they encouraged to do scholarship,
for reasons that are too long
to explain on this event,
kind of stopped using economics tools
around 1980.
Or that is to say the tools
they use go up to 1980,
but they don't use economics
after 1980 more or less.
And so, that means there's a real shortage
of academics and scholars in my field,
with whom you could debate
because the people who are
in favor of profits, aren't
really in the journals.
So, I'm sorry,
that's a kind of an incomplete
answer, but there it is.
- All right, there you go.
Thank you Fiona again, thank you for that,
and thank you for your
participation in tonight's panel.
So, this concludes our events.
Again, I'd like to thank the panelists,
and I'd also like to thank the organizers
Pam Greene, Pam Lamonaca,
Tory Bilski and Limor Peer,
we're gonna have, I guess
this is a recorded event,
so, we'll have the recording
of this event posted
at the ISPS website.
That's also the place you
can go to find out about,
upcoming ISPS events.
Thank you again for sharing
your time with us this evening,
and look forward to seeing
you at future ISPS events.
- Thanks, everyone.
- Thanks all.
- See you later on.